Hello everyone, my name is Alejandro, I'm
from Buenos Aires, Argentina. Can we look at the slides
please. Can you unlock the Mac, please. Well,
from Buenso Ares, a beautiful city. Where
you can dance tang go eat a great stake and
have some of the best wine in the world. If
you like any of those things, you should definitely
come and visit us. Awesome. Tango. I have
been writing JavaScript for a living for the
last three years, I'm also a member of the
node school Buenos Aires chapters, if you
want, come and find me after the talk, I have
stickers. Maybe some of you heard that JavaScript
turned 20 years this last May. I think that's
a really, really awesome milestone. How many
of you have been writing JavaScript for more
than five years? Okay, that's awesome, that's
kind of fifty or 70percent. How many for
more than ten years? Okay, we have 30percent.
How many for more than five teen years? Oh,
that's incredible. You should definitely talk
with them. They are very interesting people.
And I know a lot of you are thinking, but,
Aljeantr that's crazy nobody would ever think
of writing JavaScript 15 years ago and live
without it. So, what I'm trying to talk about
today is JavaScript is the compiled 2 target
for many programming languages today like
tide script, closure, dart and many, many
more. And Surma talked about this on Friday
about the state of the industry today. Also
JavaScript has been years to control electronics,
to control row boats, drones, even the lights
of a conference room, if you stayed up late
on Friday, I think that's awesome. Everyone
here could say the future of JavaScript lacks
promising. But I wound‑‑ looks promising‑‑
but I wonder, do we know where we came from,
do we know what makes JavaScript suitable
for real world applications? I hope by the
end of the talk you wall have really good
opinion on those questions. So, particularly,
we're going to talk about ECMA script, which
is the standard that which JavaScript is regularized.
And the latest version is 2015 AKA version
6. We will go through all the transition between
the previous versions to the very first one.
And after, that we're going to walk about
the time from the first release to the invention
of the language and last we're going to talk
about how the process changed committee of
ECMA script is working on the next releases.
Let's go and talk about the transition from
ES2015 to ES 5 and even if we had a full day
talking about ES6, I think we will have some
futures how we got‑‑ it's really big,
and I have very short list of some of the
most important features and controversial
too, which are classes RO functions the iter
raptors, proxies, destructuring, let and Const
and many more. For you to get an idea of how
big JavaScript is in the version 6, we have
here a graph that shows us from the left the
first release of the ECMA script standard,
and on the right, we have the last one. In
the vertical access, wev the pictures per
speck ‑‑ thee we have the pages per Spec,
we can see the first two are quite the same.
In the third one we have a‑‑ pages and
the same for the ES 5spec, but in the last
one we have more double pages. So it's quite
big. And if you don't know about any of these
features that we talked about I would strongly
suggest that you first start learning. Here
are some of the books that you could use in
the process of learning ES6, I think the second
one is not yet finished. You could ask Axel,
I think he's around here. Let's go and talk
about the transition from ES 5 to ES 4. Or
what what would have been the JavaScript version
2. Turns out, we didn't have an ES4 release,
and I think the main reason for that is because
the actual proposal for ES 4 would break the
system web at that moment. I think that's
a very compelling reason for not to release
that. Many people from Adobe Mozilla and Apple
were work on what has been done the version
of ES 4 and at the same time, another group
lead by Microsoft and Yahoo were working on
ES 3.1, a "fixed" version of ES 3. And the
work being done in ES 3.1 was tightly coupled
with what ES 4 would be, so that ended up
in a struggle between both groups and getting
consensus from both was really difficult.
From that struggle, harmony agenda was created.
And that lead to the future release that we
know today ES 5. ES 4 had also some successors
like action script version 3, which was, in
fact, a fork of JavaScript the work at Microsoft
at that moment. Here we have an extract from
a Blog post from Douglass Crockfrrord E.S
4 was so large and innovative there were doubts
that it could be successful as specified and
implemented. I think what Douglass here is
trying to tell us is that he didn't‑‑
they didn't think on among lairty, they were
too ambition in the standards body‑‑
they were trying to innovate in a standards
body Douglass later in a Blog post said he
thinks it should be the other way around,
innovation should happen outside the standard.
So, any way, let's talk about the previous,
the actual previous version of ES 5, which
was ES 3, for you to get an idea of the context,
what was happening another that moment, we
have a short timeline. ES 5 was published
on the year 20 09D and previously in the year
2006 was the first release of J query that
same year AJAX was being standardized by the
W3C committee N the year 200 40 , we have
the release of J mail, one of the first web
applications (Gmail one of the first web applications
that pushed JavaScript limits. In the year
2000 we have a black hole and the draft for
ES 3 was publish in the the year 1999. So
we have a span of ten years that there was
no new releases. Here we have Douglass and
Crawford in one of the meetings, I don't want
to say which one is on the left and which
one is on the right (Laughing) so let's talk
about what ES 5 actually introduced or we
didn't have in ES 3. One of the most important
things, I think is strict mode, strict mode
helped us to avoid global links to avoid us
weird coercion problems with con instructors,
and help us with Constroctors, introduced
betters and setters, higher order array like
RI.map and RI .4H, so JSON, who remembers
adding the JSON.JS to the library of HTML.
Not so many, awesome. Other methods like object.sale
and object.freeze, which were great if you
are in differentialsive programming paradigm
(Object.seal) one of the things that actually
got my attention was that undefined wasn't
mutable. And I think, this is in the year
2009, and what I mean with immutable is that
you could do something like this, you could
make an assignment to undefined and that actually
would take effect and supported.UI the third
party script to your page. Itaú BBA will
totally break your type check on your undefined
variables. And I think that's sucks (Laughing)
let's go on the next transition from ES 3
to ES 2. For you to have an idea was the previous
year of the release of ES 3. ES 3 introduced
one of the most important parts for popular
handling which was try/catch, we didn't have
that before ES 3, which was insane. Some of
these trick comparison, that Dimitri told
us on Friday that you should not depend on
strict comparison. And instanceof operator.
Function.apply, which was useful for method
borrowing and functional programming paradigm.
The switch statement. Function expressions.
An some of the others array helpers such as
slice, splice, contact, reverse and many,
many many more. For you to have an idea of
what the people was thinking of, during the
specification here are some reserved words
for ES 2, which are a lot, if you know most
of these features and key words, it's because
from 40 of them, 38 are also a Java key word.
And this should tell us that the people working
in the specification would denied they were
trying to make JavaScript to look like a Java‑like
programming, which was in fact unfortunate.
Going from the ESG to ES 1 specification we
at no time have too much changes, which should
be normal because it was only 7 pages difference.
But let's come out from the first release
of the specification to the actual creation
of the language, which the name was originally
Mocha. And the things that I found was quite
awkward because I wouldn't‑‑ I wouldn't
had anything to read, there was no Blog post
about how JavaScript or Mocha should work.
So, the only thing that I had is the browser,
at least the browser implementation at that
moment. For you to have an idea of the context
was the year '95 and other inventions that
year was the Java programming language, Ruby
and PHP which seemed a really good year to
inSeptember a language. One of the features
I found on browser implementation was that
con instructor property couldn't be set by
assignment. This was the actual error message
that the browser would send to you if you
tried to assign to that property, I don't
know if this was a browser limitation or it
was on the original JavaScript spec. You didn't
have any acor object literals, so for creation
of objects and arrays you would have to write
the whole new object, new array, can you imagine
that, using nine characters? That's crazy.
And, at that point, any JavaScript error would
open up a pop up in your browser, which was,
it seems really bad decision. And I learned
this because by accident I typed in Google
and press enter and what happened next was
a really nice rainbow of pop ups saying that
you had a lot of errors because it was ES
5, of course. Nobody would ever run ES 1.
And if‑‑ after too many of those pop
ups, you would have another one saying that
you would have too many errors, that kind
of sarcastic. (Laughing) for method implementations
on the global option, you would have something
like this if you tried to check if something
is undefined. And my reaction was, well, you're
kind of‑‑ true, it's true, undefined
is not defined. (Laughing) and then I realized,
oh, you're asking me to implement undefined,
which was not a reference, so I wrote a pretty
library that could polyfill undefine. It's
called undefine.JS, and it has only one line
and it seems kind of like this: So you assign
to your undefine without the bar statement,
so it's global, and (Without the Var statement
so it's global) and you should write void,
for those that are not familiar with the void
operator, it would return undefined no matter
what you have on the right side, and for the
interesting part of this implementation on
the browser, the right part doesn't have to
be defined variable to that to work. So, you
could write any Gibberish on the right side
and it would work any way that's kind of crazy.
Another implementation that I want to try
was to polyfill the method option.create.
And if you remember we didn't have functions
expressions so to create functions you need
to use the function con instructor and Dimitri
audalso, for con instructor functions for
functions and objects, it's the same if you
write the new or‑‑ the new or without
new, it would behave the same. So I'm using
that. And what I'm trying to say with this
is a lot of features that we use today could
have been used on the first version of JavaScript
or Mocha. But, let's go back today and the
future of the next specification. Turns out
there was a lot of changes since the committee
started working, and especially since they
started working on ES6. I think they realized
that the web was moving so fast that they
needed faster and more predictable release
processes. And that ended up in a train model
adoption for releases, so right now, we should
have a release of the specification, hopefully,
once a year. The next‑‑ the next change
that the committee had was the incorporation
of members who are not representative of major
browser vendors, I think that's really great
to have a really healthy committee and more
diverse. And the last important change was
for the committee to be as open as possible.
Not open in the sense that hey, I want to
be part of TC 39, yeah, sure, come in, but
in the sense that all the proposals and all
the meeting notes are available for anyone
to read. You can join the ES discuss mail
or look at the‑‑ or look at GitHub.
They have really nice organization. Here are
some research that I used to prepare my talk.
The last one, is a talk‑‑ summit this
February, it was featured by many TC 39 contributors.
That's all. Thank you.